ich würde sagen da liegen interessante
jahre vor uns meine damen und herren
zumal trump ja auch den welthandel den
handel zwischen nationen nicht als
austausch sieht sondern auch als krieg
was machen wir da also als deutsche ich
kenne eigentlich nur einen den man darf
fragen könnte
gernot hassknecht erklärt wie man mit
donald trump fertig wird in nur 100
sekunden so sofort hören wir alle auf zu
heulen wieder fort denn dieser
blondierte bauunternehmer in die
weltspitze hat löst in europa nackter
panik aus
nicht wenn wir ihnen vorher den
handelskrieg erklären bisschen mehr
selbstbewusstsein meine fresse strafzoll
auf bmw bitteschön bauen wir eben
strafzölle auf jeden big mac dann passt
meine frau vielleicht auch wieder in
ihren verdanken badeanzug und wo wir
gerade dabei sind vielleicht nehmen wir
irgendwann sogar mal steuern von amazon
oder google steuern zimmer gehört da
muss man was abgeben
von dem was man verdient hat kann ja mal
google
er kann auf gar nichts hier ich schmeiße
mein iphone mac und hole mir stattdessen
das gute deutsche von 7 aus dem vfb
handy kombinat bitterfeld europa schlägt
die usa mit letzterer anteil am
welthandel höheres bruttoinlandsprodukt
sogar unser kaffee schmeckt besser
deswegen werde ich jetzt in einem
symbolischen akt in diesem lande
karamell frappuccino besser und er wird
danach besser schmecken als verehrt
nicht weit vom tisch
gernot hassknecht
wer augen guter wirtschaftsminister
[Applaus]